how
[Music]
[Applause]
I see you rapping along to biggie listen
up girl did you say the n-word or not
because you look like I need to know you
can go ahead oh you at the last show
thank you for coming back dude did you
say the n-word or not be honest you guys
are in your car right this song comes on
you're going to the club she feeling fly
if you don't know now you know does she
does she suddenly get real quiet like
she doesn't know what's about to happen
or does she say that [ __ ] from her soul
because I'm a guy that will never say
the n-word I will just bleep it out if
I'm by myself
I'm that afraid of black people after
sunset they be blending in you know I
mean I never know what could be so if
you don't know now you know they know
you know who they are and they know
maybe I don't know as well as them but
they do but that's a line when you
[ __ ] when you're singing that song
you feel yeah maybe that's the time if
you are God who uses it you use it right
there you know I mean so what is your
ethnicity your latina
what kind of latina I'm just kidding no
one cares it's all the same it's all the
same there's a trick question
dumpling what kind of Latino are you
just Hispanic is Mexican you understand
I live in New York we got different ones
Mexicans are rare in New York we got
Puerto Ricans we got Dominicans I didn't
know they don't like each other you know
there's all these little beefs I thought
it was just India Pakistan I thought
that was the only intercultural beef
then nobody knew about except does Sun
Dominicans in Puerto Ricans [ __ ]
Haiti I pointed her cuz it's all we got
right now
Dominicans in Puerto Ricans don't like
each other it's the same [ __ ] as us and
at the end of the day all of us just
like light-skinned people it's a weird
thing as always that's a big deal right
being light-skinned she like yeah you
take her to your parents right away
right that's a girl right but if she was
Dominican you'd be like chill are you a
doctor or something I can brag about
yeah how long y'all been together four
years oh that's what's up
okay she putting the pressure on you
yeah yeah my girl put the [ __ ]
pressure on me breath as she was 48
minutes a hell Jesse in my face why are
they getting married she just looked at
her man to see if he was laughing that's
the [ __ ] you do you can't even let this
man have fun at the crazy [ __ ] I'm
staying
ain't that wild that the idea that he
might have fun at a comedy show offends
you what the [ __ ] dude what do you
bought tickets what you think this is
gonna be because there's a vagina
monologues no
for you this for him I am his mouthpiece
and I know you're gonna go home and be
like so what did you think of the show
and then he's gonna have to lie and be
like well I thought it was offensive
no why we can't just be progressive let
the man be honest that she was great he
said all the things I wanted to say but
don't because I love you yes every blog
you read is stupid but I'm not gonna
tell you I let him do it try to chuckle
to myself and then you ruin that